tonight a dire warning from defense
secretary James Madison North Korea
should cease any consideration of
actions that would lead to the end of
its regime and the destruction of its
people warlike language Matt is also
telling the world North Korea's military
will continue to be grossly over matched
by ours and would lose any arms race or
conflict a very different tone than
Madison's previous statements
emphasizing diplomacy and what war would
mean for South Korea it will involve the
massive shelling of an allies capital
which is one of the most densely packed
cities on earth it would be a war that
fundamentally we don't want Kim
jong-un's regime undeterred
any plans to execute the preventive war
devised by the US would be met with an
all-out war wiping out all the
strongholds of enemies including the US
mainland all of this after North Korea
threatened to attack Guam a u.s.
territory in the western Pacific where
US bombers are based in other aircraft
that could be used to attack his regime
he has been very threatening beyond a
normal state Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson says Trump's warning would
hopefully keep Kim from reacting I think
it was of course he delivered that
message to avoid any miscalculation on
their part
if Tillerson was playing good cop mattis
and the president were not North Korea's
best not make any more threats to the
United States they will be met with fire
and fury like the world has never seen
the commander of u.s. missile defenses
told CNN the u.s. can defend against
North Korean missile today and in the
future we can deal with the current
threat as presented today
as the threatened matures we will we
have to plan in place to mature IQ
abilities to deal with that's right the
Secretary of State still trying to
reassure I had nothing that I have seen
a nothing that I know of would indicate
that the situation has dramatically
changed in the last 44 hours I think
Americans should sleep well at night